[Music]
i myself
cannot get vaccinated and that's why i
need other people around me to be
vaccinated so they can protect
me and others like me
my name is boris lava i'm from sofia
bulgaria i'm a two-time kidney
transplanted patient
my first transplantation was made when i
was nine years old in pakistan
at the time they were doing organ
transplants to children in bulgaria
my second transplantation was done two
years ago
in turkey and my grandmother became my
kidney donor
what is happening right now is
absolutely not new for me i had to
take very good care of my hygiene what
i'm touching
am i touching my face afterwards and so
on so i really started noticing these
things even back then
so i feel like now i'm a bit more
experienced let's say
[Music]
for example my colleagues decided to
also get the seasonal flu vaccine so i
can work in a safe and
protected environment for which i'm very
thankful
[Music]
i can protect myself by raising
awareness so others protect
themselves and by doing that they
protect me so
by the herd immunity life would have
been easier for sure if
more people were vaccinated because that
would mean that i wouldn't have to
skip school and stay at home by myself
for the whole winter
hopefully we achieve that someday so
more people like me don't have to feel
so isolated
vaccines work be curious and find your
information from trusted sources